[Music]  what do you think if you were  like i was thinking if i do you think  that's a blessing or a curse being that  hot it's a double-edged sword yeah it's  double-edged sword because  i think there's more pros and cons than  cons for her for sure she's a  billionaire off it  well yeah you know how to [ __ ] use it  but at the same time like the guys  you're going for  they're all going to cheat on you  cam look like she's going for like so  she gets access to these guys but  they're all going to cheat on you  all of them  probably like what  you're going to even kanye was cheating  on her probably well he was the that i  forgot there was some famous singer that  he  that he hooked up with i was also  married and i can't remember her name  but  so it's kind of like a double-edged  sword if you can't get over that like  what do you do